hey guys it's malia um my personal life
seems to be quite the topic at the
moment
below deck star malia white is speaking
out about her breakup from
tom checkets and captain sandy yon's
recent suggestion that they split
because malia
is gay i was just as shocked as everyone
else it all
started when sandy an openly gay woman
claimed on cameo that she and others
have questioned malia's sexuality
i think secretly gay to be honest
that's my opinion everybody in
production thinks that
this is gonna be public isn't it well on
tuesday malia hit up
instagram to confirm that she and tom
who joined season five of the bravo
series midway through
as a new yacht chef have indeed broken
up
so first off yes tom and i have split um
the details surrounding all of it i am
trying to keep a little private
um just out of respect to him and i um
but yes i am single
then the reality star addressed those
comments about her sexuality
captain sandy's cameo um i was just as
shocked as everyone else i'm not sure
why my sexual
orientation is being discussed in cameos
um
first off if i was gay i would just like
to say it should be
my decision when and if to out it to the
entire internet
um but no i'm not and if i was i would
be
openly proud to be gay i'm a huge
supporter of the community and
yeah i'll just leave it at that shortly
after the 30 year old posted the clip to
social media
captain sandy issued an apology writing
on her insta story quote
i was wrong for making that comment that
clip was taken out of context
it was spliced to make it into something
it was not my apologies to malia
and when e.t caught up with sandy in may
she had
nothing but high praise for malia
malia's experience
she's bringing it so i get to witness
her how she leads her debt crew and i
get to witness how the debt crew respond
to malia
i'm hoping they do you know they respond
to her authority
and then hopefully by the end of the
season they they respect her as a person
and
trust her and so that's my hope for
malia anyway
back to malia's post you know i've made
a ton of mistakes um i am only human
um and i don't think i've been as vocal
on social media as maybe some people
want me to be or expect me to be
she also opened up about the criticism
she's faced from
fans as this season of below deck med
airs
just to recap malia was deemed
responsible for
long-time cast member and chief
stewardess hannah ferrier
getting fired from the boat i think it's
definitely
different to any season the viewers have
ever seen before when it comes to me
yeah hannah was fired after malia
discovered she had undocumented
prescriptions on board their yacht
and turned that info into sandy who
ultimately
let hannah go this is how it ends
stand by captain sandy's gonna have a
meeting
i'm very aware of the maritime laws i've
been in yachting for years
it was a mistake on my part when it
comes to the crew it's a zero tolerance
okay a crew cannot be on medication
or doing drugs or have drugs on board
because we're
we are responsible for lives hannah and
malia's co-star asha scott
opened up about the whole thing to et
earlier this month
i feel like malia's obviously just
someone who is
very very passionate about her job and
she's like a real stickler for the rules
um
so yeah i guess that's probably why
she felt inclined to like take the photo
and report it because she is just so
passionate about her job so
yeah i don't know i guess i guess i see
where she's coming from
some fans theorized that malia turned
her in to get revenge on hannah for
turning down her request to move bunks
on the boat
to room with tom i'm really sorry if i
have disappointed anyone
with my actions or you know whatever
else
it may be but i am learning um from a
personal standpoint and a professional
you know this is all new to me and i can
only hope to grow from
each and every experience um so bear
with me please
and i am listening and i appreciate the
feedback um
even if you don't hear from it um and
yeah i hope this clears the air
and thanks for listening